you better pose down I like the cuff
thing you know the rock does it yeah and
if the rock does it so should I care
bascially oh [ __ ]
mercy is a guy who is always persistent
you know never back him down was there a
time in Hollywood where you were like I
kinda want to give up you know what no
I've been so lucky that I've been really
blessed with some amazing opportunities
there was one moment in my life where I
had a bit of a rough patch and get
everything that I'd like to have got and
my mom actually sent me to a carpentry
school to try and broaden my horizons
you may be blinded career in something
else but I was lucky enough that I was
able to bang spider-man just in case now
she's happy now you're on a roll well as
method as I hear as everybody was kind
of getting on set I read that you went
to a Bronx High School here's the
spider-man no I'm not I'm not
what was the weirdest interaction that
you had in school I think the weirdest
interaction I had was I was sitting next
to this very pretty girl in class and I
tried to tell her that I was spider-man
and she didn't believe me
she thought I was lying she was like
what's your secret I was like I'm
actually spider-man she's I dude you're
so foolish I don't know what you're
talking about I know seriously I'm an
actor I'm playing spider-man it's like
dude you're nuts I don't believe you at
all
[Music]